man hey David I'm trying to get thee to  was open but I'm having the most  difficult time doing it do you have  anything these tubes are so hard to cap  a non cap always doing my fingers  blisters I feel like my fingers are  about to start bleeding I just can't do  this anymore  stupid caps stupid tubes  oh my nail yeah Oh what is this I've  never seen one before  that is a scrapper with the scrapper you  can cap and D cap separated PCI strips  boom you can cat and D cap attached PCI  strips BAM and two mil tubes no problem  got that snap and then you got sealing  films you can scrape those two what  what's the sound for stealing films yeah  what